non essentiels dans une démarche de
recherche d'emploi le cv est pour nous
aider à construire le nôtre nous
rejoignons valentin pouillard bonjour
vous êtes co fondateur de cv designer
alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de mon
cv actuelle dans la démarche de
recherche d'emploi
alors nicolas ton cv déjà bien construit
des structures est néanmoins ya quand
même quelques améliorations à apporter
la première chose de titres
j'ai vécu la bouteille c'est un cv
pourquoi écrire cb sur un cv c'est
évident on va commencer par préciser un
petit peu quel type de poste tu va
rechercher en charge du marketing charge
le marketing typiquement c'est ce qu'il
faudrait que je vais écrire ici ensuite
dans la construction de ton cv la
première chose c'est que tu vas mettre
diplômes et formations en premier t'es
un professionnel n'est plus dans le
monde étudiant hop je vais pouvoir
déplacer trop hâtivement j'ai déjà pas
mal d'expérience professionnelle dans
différentes entreprises
bien sûr ok valorise le est mêlé en
premier c'est la première chose que tu
va vouloir partager avec un recruteur
c'est l'expérience que tu acquise par le
passé ensuite il ya une section très
très important du cv que tu as commencé
à travailler et ça c'est super choix qui
néanmoins on va se pencher dessus la
partie compétences les compétences elles
se distinguent entre quatre grandes
catégories suivant les compétences
informatiques des compétences
opérationnelles dit métiers et savoir
être
le soft skills chose qui soit assez à la
mode et enfin les compétences de
lampions à ce sujet là il ya des codes à
respecter sur les compétences métiers
tels que tu les as fait tu a déterminé
des types de missions de tâches et des
compétences opérationnelles que tu es
capable de monopoliser au sein
d'entreprises ça c'est super en revanche
sur la partie des langues films et des
barres de compétences est ce que tu
penses que ça met en valeur pour niveau
ce qui va intéresser l'entreprise c'est
pas de savoir si tu es un niveau expert
ou experts puissent plus c'est
simplement de savoir si tu es
opérationnelle sur le terrain
donc ça veut dire est ce que tu es
capable de tenir une conversation est ce
que tu vas passer des certifications
dans typiquement si tu as passé un toît
quintaux fun ça va donner une idée
réelle et s'en sert de ton niveau de
langue c'est des informations qu'il faut
à tout prix faire figurer sur le procédé
d'accord concernant ce que vous aviez
dit allez le savoir être les atouts vous
alors vous c'est plutôt à tous sur votre
site quand j'y suis allé c'était
vraiment distingué comme à tout ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut vraiment mettre
en avant parce que ça peut faire la
différence
absolument et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on appelle ça le bloc des
atouts les savoir-être
ça parle à certaines personnes ça ne
parle pas à d'autres
c'est un atout pour vous parce que
lorsque vous avez 2 cv qui présente un
profil avec une expérience et des
compétences métiers qui sont plus ou
moins similaires la différence vous la
faites sur vos compétences personnelles
sur vos attitudes et sous vos
comportements
c'est la raison pour laquelle ce bloc a
toute sa place sur son cv et qui permet
de renvoyer une image un peu plus
complète de votre profil professionnel
alors ça c'est sur le fond maintenance
sur la forme si on doit reconstruire
pensé mon cv
comment ça va se passer et vous avez
justement sur votre site internet on
peut vraiment l'aménager bien
correctement
le principe de ces designers points
comme c'est de se créer un compte
gratuit dans lequel on va vous proposer
des modèles de cv rien de plus facile
pour construire son cd qui est d'avoir
une base sur laquelle on va pouvoir très
facilement passer d'un modèle à l'autre
l'objectif c'est de vous faire gagner du
temps sur la mise en forme de votre cv
et de pouvoir y organiser les
informations pour donner un vrai sens
conformément à votre objectif
professionnel
donc on peut aussi changer complètement
la forme et être un peu plus savoir
ainsi les tendances 1 exactement ce que
tu me disais c'est que tu es sur un
poste de chargée de marketing le
marketing et de la communication c'est
donner envie aux gens de lire de
découvrir son produit sur le cv c'est
avec la même chose donc donner envie aux
recruteurs de regarder ton cv ça veut
dire aussi mettre en valeur en fonction
de la forme quelque chose qui est un
petit peu plus séduisant
voilà est en fait finalement on peut
arriver à ce genre de choses et pourquoi
ce modèle là et mieux que celui
auparavant tout simplement parce que
lorsqu'on les met côte à côte
tu vas avoir un côté attractif attractif
pour l'oeil du recruteur donc notre
notamment lorsque tu va postuler à des
offres
tu as énormément un concurrent le
première étape c'est de donner
l'occasion recruteurs de lire et
découvrir ton cv ensuite c'est au niveau
de la lisibilité des informations mettre
en avant des contrastes par rapport aux
typologies police par rapport aux
couleurs ça va donner naissance de
lisibilité
tout en soulignant mais vraie force
autre profil merci martin brouillard